isn't that something that like when
you're this macho football player
hanging out with the guys and then you
go into theater do guys give you hell
for that when you become an actor and
you're you're part of that whole
thing i didn't care
yeah it was like i
i woke up then i i just found something
that i loved were you good at it right
away or did it take time yeah i would
you know i was always goofing on in
class you mean you were good at the
beginning like when someone said to you
become a character
would you think about somebody you knew
in your life and become that character
use whatever i could what did you use
because i'm i'm amazed that by actors
who are really good and you're one of
them do you think about somebody you
know in your life yeah and then do an
impression i'd steal it from another
movie
real would you yeah like like
pacino doing something i'd use that
do you do impressions actual literal
impressions you know what i did when i
was like in seventh and eighth grade to
get out of beatings who did
yeah i could do
a lot of impressions and i'd do it for
the hard guys like in the hall and they
would take care of me when you get hired
to do revenge of the nerds do you sit
there and go i saw pacino do something
so in this character i'm gonna i'm gonna
do no that one was pretty uh pretty
self-starting i i used a couple of
football coaches that i knew and so you
behaved like that yeah yeah yeah so as a
military guy is acting doing an
oppression in a sense are you an
impressionist
uh in the beginning
i was a little bit because i was
floundering just desperate to
to grab anything but uh
you know later on when i learned a
little more um
i got to it on my own and i'm still
learning are you yeah which is which is
great that's a godsend because uh
knowing that i don't know everything and
and now i'm just trying to simplify
everything all right take me through
this did you ever uh do tv commercials
you've got a very deep voice yeah do you
ever do like those voiceovers
i did a couple i did uh dunkin donuts
dunkin donuts red roof in um do you put
on that voice you know dunkin donuts uh
yeah yeah what do you know whatever they
want
let's let's get it over with it is that
the meaning for an actor
you know what when i started doing
commercials
i i started hanging out with um really
really good actors broadway actors film
actors and i felt terrible because i was
making dough um
doing a lot of commercials you felt like
uh you felt terrible because you were
taking money away from
other people what would what no i
thought cause that's how i was making my
living smiling and eating hamburgers i
see in other words you felt bad because
that's not what you got into acting yeah
yeah yeah and i was taking myself just a
little too seriously well the point is
though what's wrong with that what's
wrong with doing in television it's
acting it's still happening yeah and
actors have to work and i learned a lot
from it and um i i supported myself
right did you think at the time though
that maybe you were getting too
comfortable oh you weren't gonna stretch
i i i tried to stretch i i you know i um
i still went out and did regional
theater
um
but it it just it felt like this is
where i'm going to wind up is it true
you were the guy who they slapped in the
face and and said thanks i needed that
yeah you got skin braces
skin braces yeah you were the guy that
was the first uh first big commercial
you go slap myself in the face and you
go thanks i needed that yeah yeah that
must have paid a fortune handsome young
buck yeah at the time yeah i was broke
and uh
yeah as soon as i started making money
it's uh when my ass at the bar stool oh
yeah yeah if that was your downfall i
said they shouldn't pay you
thanks so much
thanks for looking out for me